Delta flight landed without nose gear
safely
I got a lot of thoughts on this so like
simultaneously to when I was flying
Delta this Delta plane going into
Charlotte had to make emergency landing
without the [__] front wheel like
what do you give to your passengers oh
you want a free flight no I'm never
flying again in my life [__] I need to
check for this yeah KRS one only but
I'll leave uh ships stay only ships
goes in boats
it gets a little cargo boxes
front of this plane is not
tore up from what you see like because
that's a ball and ass pilot so you're
coming down your back wheels down now
your front slams and it's on fire and
it's like shooting everywhere but it
looks pretty good though it looks pretty
good it does that's just probably a
picture from someone else it could be
before they took off